Eating Bad? Whose Fault Is It?
Every one of us has to make decisions about what we eat every day of our lives.
The older we get, the more we think about this.
However, it is also important when we are young,...
...for poor nutrition in the formative years...
...may lead to problems that don't appear until we are older.
For example, low intake of calcium at an early age may lead to various bone disorders as we age.
Consider this.
In America where obesity is common,...
...health complications related to obesity are a huge problem...
...and increase the cost of health care for everyone.
The issue has even been submitted to the courts to decide if the government...
...or an individual food company is liable for damages to an individual...
...if that individual has become sick, obese,...
...or has health problems from eating too much bad food.
I haven't settled on a position yet concerning this issue.
But until the time when I come to a conclusion,...
...I'm going to take responsibility for my own actions...
...and not blame the government, or fast food restaurants, if I get fat from eating too much bad food.